so what's going on with white collar
that's a great question i have no idea i
mean i i threw my hat in the ring and
told jeff easton
if he could find a way to do it and find
a home for it and a way that worked
everyone's schedules and and wasn't you
know uh you know
16 episodes for six years um then then
you know i'd be there to
to to throw that fedora on and work with
that incredible cast who i love and
adore and speak to
weekly still um but i you know
so much of what goes into that is is way
above my pay grade and beyond my control
you know i'm not going to put a pitch
together as to what the arc of the show
should be or what the story needs to be
or where it needs to be that it's sort
of up to
him and whatever platform would want to
produce it yeah i was wondering if you
guys would ever do like the two hour
movie versus like doing another 10
episodes
that was my pitch is to do a two-hour
movie and just see how it goes
you know and get everybody back together
or even four hours do two two hour
movies or four or
one hours whatever it is to tell just
one
uh storyline and uh and just to see how
it goes that's kind of what my pitch was
i don't know if that's
like i don't know commercially how that
fits into the paradigm in this day and
age i don't know if that's something
that's
interesting to people i'm not sure but
that would be i would love to do
something like that
uh congratulations on doing patrol thank
you
uh i know that you guys got the season
three for
hbo max yes um so what's going on when
do you start filming that have no idea
i mean i honestly i have the only things
that are really real that i've that have
come my way
um film overseas at this point
um and i just can't lead my family uh
during the election
and holidays at this time there's just
too much going on so
um i hopefully uh you know when things
pick up when
say i i'm hearing that sets that people
are on are really safe and trustworthy
and i'm
hopefully i'll be back in atlanta in the
new year and we'll be working on season
three but
i don't have any official word on
anything